[MUSIC PLAYING]
RACHEL PETTERSON: Steve is an
interactive art installation.
He is a giant
Joshua tree that is
covered with LEDs and sensors.
CARSON HOLGATE: So I
had this general idea
for an interactive tree.
It needed lights somehow.
And I realized as
I was designing it
that it was going to be this
20 foot by 20 foot giant tree.
RACHEL PETTERSON: I worked
specifically on the sensors.
And so these were the
force resistive sensors,
the light sensors,
and the sound sensors.
And then I also
worked with Aieswarya
on the gesture sensors
AIESWARYA MANICKA: Going left,
going right, hovering over it,
kind of waving motion.
The idea behind
it was we would be
able to hide it in knots
in the tree type of thing.
So if they do something
like this or this,
then the color
can change and you
get that interaction feeling.
RACHEL PETTERSON: So the sensors
are all slightly different.
The light sensor
takes in the light
and outputs a digital signal.
The force resistive
sensor takes in input
and outputs an analog signal.
The last one is the
sound sensor, which
is actually just a microphone.
And Android Things has
a built-in audio driver,
which we were able to use, and
then do a calculation for what
the average volume was.
So we would take small
snippets and calculate
the average volume,
and that would give us
a reading at that
given time for how
loud everything was around it.
CARSON HOLGATE: When we
were working out the sensors
and the tree itself,
we knew that it
needed to communicate somehow,
because they're all connected
to separate development boards.
So the tree is completely
separate from the sensors.
And instead of
trying to figure out
Bluetooth or some other
communication method,
which you usually have
to do on other platforms,
we could just plug in Firebase.
There were libraries and
it kind of just worked.
And the sensors would
write about every second,
or whatever the refresh rate
was, to part of the Firebase
database, and then we
used cloud functions
to turn those into
some aggregate values
to send to the boards
controlling the light show.
And that way, we were able
to adjust the tolerances
during the day.
And if it was too noisy, we
could change the tolerances
for the sound
sensors, and we were
putting AstroTurf over the
pressure sensors in the floor.
So depending on how that
affected the pressure,
we could also adjust
that on the fly.
RACHEL PETTERSON: Working
with Android Things
was a really good experience,
because, since I already
had Android
development experience,
I was able to really focus on
learning all about the sensors.
So although I had some
experience with wiring up
an LED here or there,
I hadn't really
worked with this
variety of sensors
to gather information
from the environment.
Android Things let
me really expand
that knowledge of
sensors, while being
in the very comfortable Android
environment that I knew well.
AIESWARYA MANICKA: I would
just say to just get started.
There's actually so
many resources online
with tutorials.
Like Android Things,
the kit points you
towards so many things
you can do with the kit.
There are so many sensors
that come in the kit,
so you don't actually need
to buy additional sensors.
You can do a lot with
just what's in the kit.
RACHEL PETTERSON: If you're
interested in getting started
with Android Things,
I highly recommend
checking out the codelabs
that they have online.
Android Things has also set up
a repository of sample drivers,
and these drivers are
really good examples,
whether you're looking to write
your own driver for a sensor
you've picked up, or if you've
picked up a sensor that matches
one of these drivers, it's a
really easy way to get started.